you're retired and do you rock can you
believe this today we've had a very
weird day like this has come up like
four times today
since the last daily be this could be
like a whole fun thing to do right what
happened I went to the west coast from
Super Bowl spent some great time with
Stephen Ross owner of the Miami Dolphins
my business partner bought into
vaynermedia several years ago and and he
knows an NFL owner you know I like that
so gotta spend some nice time with him
at the Super Bowl
how's that possible
because I don't like these things on
Facebook live we need to get you honest
this guy's became of social media that
following his guy ought to then I went
and had some meetings in LA followed up
with a trip to San Diego's Beckham you
know CDM spoke at a large digital
conference which I enjoyed very well
organized
hey corporate American [ __ ] this is
how everybody now watches TV the reason
their hands they don't watch it when it
airs which means they're not watching
your [ __ ] [ __ ] commercial then I
took a red-eye to Miami
met with a Lexus which is a division
within Toyota which is a client of
vaynermedia's gave a speech to senior
executives there did some podcasting
showed up in some social did a lot of
snapchatting make sure you're following
that and now getting really focused on
the book you know it's very close if you
haven't ordered your copies yet please
do if I brought you any value in life an
order would mean a lot to me we've got
the super 8 coming up buy ebooks get a
lotto ticket for February 23rd so focus
day at sea Steve Ross today who's here
Benjamin sighted yeah hello man hey this
is my daily meters my videoblog
Masterson I'm Howard if all you wanna be
you know to be famous and that's exactly
what's about to happen and Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr Facebook Twitter
YouTube and Instagram or ABC NBC and CBS
and what I've figured out for the last
decade is how to make how to make Julian
beans or Miller wafers which was flat
for 11 years but with $800,000 I grew
12% with no support I figured out how to
make mash and the Anna Griffin Show and
ER inside velman oh it's a lot more no
it's not even close yeah well connect
I'll see you right away
you're the biggest consumer you you were
the biggest that the thing that I want
to do for my song I like interested they
more hand and watching me and carry the
image of pitch it should be a show in
itself it is the show it's such a crazy
thing it's such a crowd you know what
happens like it like yeah black out that
I literally get possessed big meeting
about resi our restaurant app it's going
super well Steve uh I'm gonna let Ben do
most of talking but the reason we're
together now is we've got some really
exciting stuff going on with resi leave
the app
two minutes are you running late so I'd
like to be like a strategy intern but I
know that I can be an asset and I'm so
certain that I can help that I'll work
the first month or two for free send me
an email
I'll sit with you for five minutes for
the next two weeks good luck to you
you're welcome and hello
oh is this us oh I'm so sorry not this
my guy wasn't happy with me good how are
you I'm going to LinkedIn that should be
a lot of fun no you get up working hard
Thanks so good oh thank you for being
here yeah special talent oh I can I can
do this with my tongue LinkedIn is a
tremendous company and they'll be fun to
speak to some of their executives hired
do you rock can you believe this today
we've had a very weird day like this has
come up like four times today I don't
have a trick I don't know what's
happening it's uh it's called
anonymously lucky DNA know how your time
that's something that's been the best
part of daily be now people really know
how busy I am you know so you guys do we
have your an hour
what's up my man what's going on
you ready for your daily via it's like
literally like let's call it what it is
snapchat and add daily be are really
just vehicles for me to impose my will
on everybody to just once and for all
eliminate the converse like I want to
basically want people to be embarrassed
right take the link above ours today
yeah I'm sorry but that does know
everybody should do their thing just
embarrassed to say they do work as hard
as me right you might be smarter and
make more money and you're better and
your better yeah but the one thing
you're not allowed to say is that you
work hard like that's just
if you think that that the idea of
hustle culture is becoming is becoming
like please shed
like the thing about your Hustle is its
hustle with tons of substance right but
I feel like there's a lot of kids who
are just hustling to awesome and like
they just they're like well I think a
lot of kids are saying they're hustling
ghazal you know what I mean
that's what you don't that's what I'm
getting yeah I mean in my way by the way
I'm just doing it to help the people
that are actually trying to do it
realize how much work it is I actually
hope somebody else comes out with daily
Z and shows unbelievable work-life
balance right
it just shows her or his seven hour days
but just enormous amounts of happiness
with family and bowling and learning new
I'm gonna learn how to knit this week
like there I don't I don't want to
convince anybody to do what I do I just
want to clarify to everybody that it
like you say so this is what you mean
I'm just it look it takes a lot of work
and you know the other thing that's
really helped a lot of people is people
like whoa you're already way more
successful than I am and I'm working
like half as much as you and I thought I
was working more than you because I
thought you were kind of saying it but
then weeping the benefits of the riches
if you're still doing that so it's a
context point so it's come up because of
my last 24 hours on snap you think um
not really you know
you know like once like four times a
year like aw like collapse and go to
sleep at like 7:00 p.m. and I'll need
like a hard core like 15 hour sleep but
and I started taking care of my health
about two years ago 18 months ago and I
was not I mean I don't think I picked up
any more energy when I was 25 pounds
heavier and eating like [ __ ] and not
exercising I just have so much a natural
adrenaline I showed up to somebody's
podcast yesterday and he was Facebook
liveing and I went back and read all the
comments last night at midnight because
I don't get tired and literally
everybody's like this guy's on [ __ ]
drugs which is really interesting for LA
and they meant it because they know what
was I feel like like why do all these
guys have to take drugs to like and I
was like [ __ ] I've never even tried a
cigarette I've never done anything in my
life I'm like I've been left out from
all that good [ __ ] and people still
think it because I just had it's just
natural DNA I truly think it's the same
way as being pretty or six-foot-five
it's just something you were given and
like I like it I'm glad I like that I
can I truly truly I really believe what
I'm about to say and this is
hyperbolized to the moon I truly think
I'm the hardest-working person on earth
I truly believe that I just work 18
hours a day every day like I just do
cool awesome thanks guys
ehm thank you so much like this thank
you we thank you a little internal
meetings got some late night drinks
should be a good day for 14x14